i love the way he navigated that myriad  of screams  see ya and here's the steal by luca out  of the open court for the phenom  it was the [ __ ] giving him a hard time  for not dunking it is that what i see  over here i think  i think you're on to something  [Laughter]  either way weird looking shot for rozier  again  the problem with charlotte is just not  having that go-to guy  trey burke he's strong in the corner  three green on the offside and draws a  foul  this is the second game where josh green  is in the rotation  and there's something different in terms  of maybe just looks a little bit more  settled down  tonight i think that's a a fair  assessment  as luca gets the easy basket and  he thought about a dunk i guess  [Laughter]  save your there is someone who will  never be a judge in the slam dunk  competition